This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in 2008, the so-called War on Terror was in full swing. That year, close to 190,000 US troops were stationed in the Middle East. In Afghanistan, the Taliban and other anti-government insurgents were fighting against the Afghan government and its international military partners. It was during midday or probably afternoon. I was very tired and I was just looking for a quiet remote place. This is Mustafa, who is only using his first name to protect his friends and family in Afghanistan.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。早在2008年，所谓的“反恐战争”正酣。当年，将近19万名美军驻扎在中东。在阿富汗，塔利班和其他反政府武装正在与阿富汗政府及其国际军事盟友作战。那是中午，或者可能是下午。我非常累，只是想找个安静偏僻的地方。说话的是穆斯塔法，他只用自己的名，以保护他在阿富汗的朋友和家人。
Mustafa remembers one particular day when he needed a break from the stress of life in his village. He was exhausted and so that afternoon he started looking for a quiet place to take an app. So I went in the interd in this room and I was so I'm bad there and it was a very remote area of the village.
穆斯塔法记得有那么一天，他需要从村里紧张的生活中抽身出来。他筋疲力尽，所以在那个下午，他开始找一个安静的地方小睡。于是我走进了这个房间，躺在床上，那是村里非常偏远的一个地方。
He went into the house and quickly fell asleep. Next thing I know there were Marines kicking in the village. He went into the house and quickly fell asleep. Next thing I know, there were Marines kicking in the door, people with the gun strong, they came in yelling and they say, oh we got him, we got him and then I was like I didn't know what to do. Before he knew it, Mustafa had been handcuffed and taken in for interrogation. They were like, what you were doing? Where did you come from?
他走进屋里，很快就睡着了。我回过神来时，海军陆战队员正破门而入，持枪的人冲进来大喊，哦，我们抓到他了，我们抓到他了，然后我就不知所措了。在他还没反应过来之前，穆斯塔法就被戴上手铐，带去审讯。他们质问：你在干什么？你从哪里来？
And they were on a farm that was a suspected Taliban house. It could have been a catastrophe from Mustafa, except it wasn't real. Because the entire situation was a military simulation. Best reporter, Sonya Paul. Mustafa, who was born in Afghanistan and raised as a refugee in Pakistan, was playing a role in a make-believe theater of war.
他们当时在一个农场里，这是一个疑似塔利班据点的房子。对穆斯塔法来说，这本可能是一场灾难，但事实并非如此。因为整个情况只是一场军事模拟。本集记者索尼娅·保罗。穆斯塔法出生于阿富汗，在巴基斯坦作为难民长大，他在一个虚构的战争剧场里扮演着一个角色。
He wasn't in Afghanistan. He was in 29 palms, California, home to the world's largest Marine Corps training base. All I knew was we were going to roleplay as an Afghan character, living in a fictional country like Afghanistan, and pretend to be an Afghanistan and teach the Marines the Afghan customs and the culture. Hundreds of other Afghans were roleplaying alongside Mustafa in the scenario.
他不在阿富汗。他在加利福尼亚州二十九棕榈村，这里拥有世界上面积最大的海军陆战队训练基地。我只知道我们要扮演一个阿富汗角色，生活在一个像阿富汗这样的虚构国家里，假装自己是阿富汗人，教海军陆战队阿富汗的风俗习惯和文化。还有数百名其他阿富汗人在该场景中与穆斯塔法一起扮演角色。
Everyone had a specific role in the village, police officer, mayor, insurgent, and so on. Mustafa was playing the mayor's son. And that scenario was for them to search the house just to make sure what was going on in that house. And coincidentally, which was not part of the training, I was there just because I was taken up. Fake cities, imitation nations, people roleplaying
每个人在村里都有特定的角色，警察、市长、叛乱分子等等。穆斯塔法扮演的是市长的儿子。当时的情景是让他们搜查那所房子，以弄清楚那所房子里到底发生了什么。巧合的是，这并不是训练的一部分，我在那里只是因为我被抓了。虚假的城市，模仿的国家，人们扮演着
as civilians, spies, or enemies, complete with costumes and props. All of this was coordinated and constructed by the US military to prepare soldiers for war. These fake villages designed for US military training dot the entire United States, not to mention other countries. Researchers have identified over 400 of them around the world. Mustafa says he participated as a role player about a dozen times between the years of 2008
平民、间谍或敌人，配有服装和道具。所有这些都是由美军协调和建造的，旨在为士兵的战争做准备。这些专为美军训练而设计的假村庄遍布全美各地，更不用说其他国家了。研究人员已经在全球识别出了400多个这样的村庄。穆斯塔法说，在2008年至
in 2013. It was the heyday of military simulations, when most of them were made to look like mock villages and cities of the Middle East. They had a mosque, they had shopkeepers, they had a police force, they had an army force. It really felt after the third day that I really was in Afghanistan. But these training simulations have a much longer history. And now more than two years after US troops pulled out of Afghanistan and nearly 21 years after the invasion of Iraq,
2013年间，他作为角色扮演者参与了大约十几次。那是军事模拟的全盛时期，其中大多数被建成了模仿中东村庄和城市的模样。他们有清真寺、店主、警察部队、军队。呆了三天后，真的感觉自己置身于阿富汗。但这些训练模拟有着更长的历史。如今，在美军撤出阿富汗两年多后，在入侵伊拉克近21年后，
they're being revamped yet again for another era of warfare. In theory, these training sites are meant to prepare soldiers and protect against the loss of life. But for the role players who staff them, people like Mustafa, the sites can start to blur truth and fiction in ways that can be uncanny and raise questions about the changing nature
它们正在为另一个战争时代进行再次改造。从理论上讲，这些训练场旨在训练士兵并防止生命损失。但对于为这些训练场提供人员的角色扮演者来说，比如穆斯塔法这样的人，这些地方开始模糊了现实与虚构的界限，这种方式可能令人毛骨悚然，并引发了人们对战场不断变化的性质和战争生意的质疑。
of the battlefield and the business of war. For much of the long history of warfare, these types of urban simulations were unnecessary. Mostly because, for much of the long history of warfare, these types of urban simulations were unnecessary. Mostly because, for much of history, warfare wasn't urban at all. It happened on a battlefield. Around World War I, simple military simulations began to emerge. Infantry would often dig trenches and practice drills in them to prepare for the trench warfare on the front lines.
在漫长的战争历史中，这类城市模拟在很大程度上是不必要的。主要是因为，在漫长的战争历史中，这类城市模拟在很大程度上是不必要的。主要是因为，在历史上很长一段时间里，战争根本不是城市战。它发生在战场上。大约在第一次世界大战期间，简单的军事模拟开始出现。步兵经常挖掘战壕并在其中进行演练，以准备前线的战壕战。
But it wasn't until World War II that the military fully realized the importance of urban simulations and preparing soldiers for war. Largely in response to the 1942 Battle of Stalingrad. The Soviet soldiers adapted themselves to fighting under the ruined building. Spurred on by hatred for the enemy, they gave the German no-ret. The Salangrad was a very dense urban environment and included buildings the size of urban blocks that have multiple stories that have basements that have addicts. That's Stephen Mueller. He's an architect who studied the history and design of military training
但直到第二次世界大战，军方才充分认识到城市模拟在让士兵做好战争准备方面的重要性。这在很大程度上是对1942年斯大林格勒战役的回应。苏联士兵适应了在废墟建筑下作战。在对敌人的仇恨的驱使下，他们没有给德国人留下退路。斯大林格勒是一个非常密集的城市环境，其中包括有多个楼层、地下室和阁楼的城市街区大小的建筑物。这是史蒂芬·穆勒。他是一位研究军事训练场历史和设计的建筑师。
sites. Before this moment, infantry training might have involved some exposure to urban environments, but nothing at the scale of Stalingrad. All of the allied militaries were realizing that they were underprepared for the sheer scale and scope and complexity of prolonged warfare in a complex three-dimensional urban environment. And so then all of the allied forces, including the US, started preparing for more and more battles like that by building environments that could better simulate that. And these simulations also began to incorporate role players. So there would be, for instance, a role player playing Hitler or Gerbels, the kind of propaganda minister,
在此之前，步兵训练可能涉及一些对城市环境的接触，但没有达到斯大林格勒的规模。所有盟军都意识到，他们对复杂的三维城市环境中长期战争的纯粹规模、范围和复杂性准备不足。因此，包括美国在内的所有盟军都开始通过建造能够更好模拟这种环境的环境，来为越来越多的此类战斗做准备。这些模拟也开始吸纳角色扮演者。因此，例如会有角色扮演者扮演希特勒或宣传部长戈培尔，
and these role players would be inciting a crowd of supporters that would be better the scenario that the Allied forces would train to intervene with them. But the main focus of the military simulations was practicing for and adjusting to the complexity of different physical environments where soldiers would be fighting. The military went to great lengths to create authentic replicas of each new theater of war, like replicating the moisture content of the wood used in enemy buildings, so they can understand how a foreign
这些角色扮演者会煽动一群支持者，以便盟军进行干预训练。但军事模拟的主要焦点是练习和适应士兵将要作战的不同物理环境的复杂性。军方不遗余力地为每一个新的战区创造真实的复制品，例如复制敌方建筑物所用木材的水分含量，以便他们了解外国环境将如何对火灾和爆炸做出反应。
environment would respond to fire and explosions. The hired architects to design fake German apartment blocks and mock Japanese dwellings. They paid attention to minutia on the exterior and interior of these homes to ensure they were realistic. Over the decades, they also built roads and sewer systems to mimic the ones in Korea and eventually phony Vietnamese villages in the swamps of Louisiana. But the people piece of the battle became increasingly complex. And a major turning point for the military came out of a real conflict in the 1990s. US forces were deployed to support a United Nations humanitarian mission in Somalia.
他们聘请建筑师设计德国假公寓楼和日本假住宅。他们注重这些房屋内外的细节，以确保它们逼真。几十年来，他们还修建了道路和下水道系统，以模仿韩国的道路和下水道系统，最终还在路易斯安那州的沼泽地里建造了越南假村庄。但战斗中的人员部分变得越来越复杂。军方的一个重大转折点来自20世纪90年代的一场真实冲突。美军被部署到索马里支持联合国人道主义任务。
When a military coup devastated the country's agriculture and led to a nationwide famine. US forces ended up tangling with local warlords in the distribution of food aid. Eventually Somali forces shot down two American Black Hawk helicopters, which was dramatized in the film Black Hawk Down. An 18-hour firefight erupted in the streets in what became known as the Battle of Mogadishu. It's estimated that hundreds possibly even more than a thousand Somalis died, as did 18 American soldiers. It is missing in the heaviest fighting yet in Mogadishu, Some of the dead dragged through the streets by gearing Somalis. The worst US casualties yet in Somalia,
当时一场军事政变摧毁了该国的农业并导致了全国性饥荒。美军最终在分发粮食援助时与当地军阀发生纠缠。最终索马里武装击落了两架美军黑鹰直升机，这一幕被改编进电影《黑鹰坠落》中。摩加迪沙街头爆发了持续18小时的枪战，这就是著名的摩加迪沙战役。据估计，有数百甚至上千名索马里人丧生，另有18名美国士兵阵亡。这是摩加迪沙迄今为止最激烈的战斗，一些死者被欢呼的索马里人拖过街道。这是美军在索马里迄今为止最惨重的伤亡，
forcing the Pentagon to send reinforcements into what has become an all-out urban war. The battle was a tragedy for all those involved, and it was considered a political embarrassment for the United States. This kind of warfare was fundamentally different from the way the US military knew how to fight. For one, the built environment in Somalia was chaotic.
迫使五角大楼向这场已经演变成全面城市战的冲突中增派援军。这场战斗对所有相关人员来说都是一场悲剧，对美国来说也被认为是一次政治难堪。这种战争与美军习惯的战斗方式有着根本的不同。首先，索马里的建筑环境是混乱的。
A dense urban market built for makeshift materials like scrap metal and highly flammable wood, which meant that it could be very easily destroyed. To not have been able to really win that small gorilla warfare in Mogadishu because of the density of the urban landscape was not only lessons learned, but also like symbolic loss in a way that we hadn't seen before. This is Ursula Creepet. She and Stephen co-authored a book about the relationship between urbanism and military training. And she says that critically, the intensity battle also involved a kind of combatant the
一个由废金属和高度易燃的木材等临时材料建造的密集城市市场，这意味着它很容易被摧毁。由于城市景观的密集度而无法真正在摩加迪沙赢得那场小型游击战，这不仅是吸取了教训，而且也是一种前所未见的象征性失败。这是厄休拉·克里佩特。她和史蒂芬合著了一本关于城市主义与军事训练之间关系的书。她说，至关重要的是，战斗的激烈程度还涉及一种军方没有训练过的战斗人员。那些不能明显被识别为士兵或战斗人员的人。
military had in train for. People who weren't clearly identifiable as soldiers or fighters. The so-called enemy was enlisting people through the market and enlisting people in the neighborhoods to be on the lookout or to kind of be warning or to hide munitions. In other words, it wasn't just the environment the US military wasn't prepared for. It didn't know how to predict the people in the city, whether they were local sympathizers of the so-called enemy or civilians caught in the crossfire. Soon after the disaster in Somalia,
所谓的敌人通过市场和社区招募人员来放哨、发出警告或藏匿弹药。换句话说，美军没有准备好的不仅仅是环境。它不知道如何预测城市里的人，无论是所谓敌人的当地同情者还是卷入交火的平民。索马里灾难后不久，
and then, as the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq began, enormous amounts of funding flowed into the military to update its training. The army wanted to avoid another fiasco-like Mogadishu, and the one other soldiers better prepared to fight in cities crowded with both enemies and civilians. There was some momentum around shifting military culture at that moment. That's Professor Andy Rice, who has studied military simulations. They imagined the future of wars that they would be fighting much more like those kind of urban counterinsurgency styles of combat.
随着阿富汗和伊拉克战争的爆发，大量资金涌入军方以更新其训练。军队希望避免再次出现像摩加迪沙那样的惨败，并希望让士兵做好准备，在挤满敌人和平民的城市中作战。当时军事文化转型出现了一些势头。研究军事模拟的安迪·赖斯教授说道。他们设想未来的战争将更像是那种城市反游击战风格的战斗。
They'd also just rewritten the field training manual, I think in 2004, 2005, to emphasize culture and counterinsurgency as opposed to force-on-force combat operations. The military realized it needed to double down on training soldiers in local culture. Troops needed to understand the local politics, the traditions, and the language at the place. This could help them avoid misinterpreting signs and symbols in the ways that people Approach, let's say a checkpoint, so you know, shoot somebody and so the importance of role players in military simulations only grew They needed to speak the languages that soldiers might encounter They needed to act the ways that locals might act and their roles needed to reflect the increasingly ambiguous nature of modern warfare.
他们还刚刚重写了野战训练手册，我想是在2004年、2005年，强调文化和反叛 insurgency，而不是面对面的战斗行动。军方意识到它需要加倍努力对士兵进行当地文化训练。部队需要了解当地的政治、传统和语言。这可以帮助他们避免误解人们接近检查站时的手势和符号，从而避免开枪打死人，因此角色扮演者在军事模拟中的重要性日益增加。他们需要说士兵可能会遇到的语言，他们需要表现得像当地人一样，他们的角色需要反映现代战争日益模糊的性质。
Like this is actually a really important skill set to be able to play act in these spaces, to be able to think about your relationships with a supposed adversary. So I wanted to see it. In 2007, and again in 2012, Professor Rice visited and studied a training village in Southern California designed to look like the Middle East. Its moniker was Medina Wasel. again in 2012, Professor Rice visited and studied a training village in Southern California designed to look like the Middle East. Its moniker was Medina Wasle. Medina Wasle was like a big Hollywood production.
这其实是一项非常重要的技能，能够在这些空间里进行角色扮演，能够思考你与所谓对手的关系。所以我想看看。在2007年和2012年，赖斯教授参观并研究了南加州一个旨在看起来像中东的训练村。它的绰号是麦地那·瓦塞尔。2012年，赖斯教授再次参观并研究了南加州一个旨在看起来像中东的训练村。它的绰号是麦地那·瓦塞尔。麦地那·瓦塞尔就像是一部好莱坞大片。
Scenes and scenarios were crafted by a team of real Hollywood writers and military consultants. And the military also went to some absurd lengths to get these role players ready for their roles. They hired actors like Carl Weathers, who played Apollo Creed in the Rocky franchise, to give acting lessons. These scenarios needed to be visually dramatic as well. The military wanted soldiers to encounter the worst of the worst while training in these urban warfare scenarios. The aesthetics are meant to feel as though you're in a war. Like the military really wants its soldiers
场景和剧本由真正的好莱坞作家和军事顾问团队精心打造。为了让这些角色扮演者做好角色准备，军方甚至采取了一些荒谬的手段。他们聘请了演员，比如在《洛奇》系列中扮演阿波罗·克里德的卡尔·韦瑟斯来教授表演课。这些场景在视觉上也需要具有戏剧性。军方希望士兵在这些城市战场景中训练时遭遇最糟糕的情况。美学旨在让你感觉身处战争之中。就像军方真的希望其士兵
to be inoculated against shock is the way that they put it. So that a soldier in an actual wartime environment won't be paralyzed with fear and not act the way that they're supposed to according to their training. And creating the worst day ever morphed into an industry. Companies took notice. So there was a company out of San Diego. They had kind of made their reputation
通过他们所说的方式来进行“心理接种”，以防震惊。这样一来，处于实际战时环境中的士兵就不会因恐惧而瘫痪，从而无法按照训练要求行事。而创造“最糟糕的一天”已经演变成了一个行业。各大公司注意到了这一点。圣地亚哥有一家公司。他们通过制作大量像你知道的犯罪剧和软色情片建立了声誉。
through like high numbered cable, like, you know, lured crime dramas and soft core porn. Around the year 2002, that lured crime dramas and soft core porn. Around the year 2002, that lured crime drama and soft core porn company created an offshoot called Strategic Operations. It was founded to produce stressful, hyper-realistic combat situations for training military personnel using all the techniques of the theater, TV, and film industries. They became specialists in pirate techniques and engineering big explosions inside Medina Wasel. They also did kind of flesh-colored rubber suits that would squirt blood.
大约在2002年，那家制作犯罪剧和软色情片的公司创立了一个名为“战略行动”的分支机构。它的成立是为了利用戏剧、电视和电影行业的所有技术，为军事人员训练制作充满压力、高度逼真的战斗场景。他们成为了海盗技术和在麦地那·瓦塞尔内部制造巨大爆炸的专家。他们还制作了会喷血的肉色橡胶紧身衣。
That was another thing that they had people wear. They ended up contracting with amputees to play the roles of people that had lost limbs inside of IED explosions. This all sounds like a pretty wild thing to to play the roles of people that had lost limbs inside of IED explosions. This all sounds like a pretty wild thing to experience from the perspective of soldiers in training. But then consider the role players at Medina Wasle, the mostly Arab-American immigrants. Many had been in the U.S. since the 1970s, and they had signed up to basically play themselves in a facsimile of their home countries under brutal attack.
那是他们让人们穿的另一件东西。他们最终与截肢者签约，让他们扮演在简易爆炸装置（IED）爆炸中失去四肢的人。从受训士兵的角度来看，这一切听起来似乎是一段非常疯狂的经历。但再想想麦地那·瓦塞尔的角色扮演者，他们大多是阿拉伯裔美国移民。许多人自20世纪70年代以来就一直在美国，他们报名基本上是在遭到残酷攻击的家乡复刻版中扮演他们自己。
Mustafa doesn't remember exactly how he first found out about the job as a role player. He'd been in the US for about eight years at that point, living in Sacramento, going to school, and learning the ins and outs of life in the US when some of his friends, also from Afghanistan, started applying for the U.S. when some of his friends, also from Afghanistan, started applying for the job. It was around 2008 and I was on a spring break from my community college and I was just
穆斯塔法记不清他是怎么第一次知道角色扮演者这份工作的了。那时他在美国大约八年了，住在萨克拉门托，上学，了解美国生活的方方面面，当时他的一些同样来自阿富汗的朋友开始申请这份工作。那是2008年左右，我正在社区学院过春假，时机简直
perfect timing. I had a week off and I was a 5-day assignment. I was like, okay, it's an easy enough job, so I went there. Can you walk me through? What had happened in order for you to get the job? So we were supposed to meet up at this restaurant, which was also a bankered hall in Fremont. Fremont, California, home to one of the largest Afghan
太完美了。我有一周的假，这是一个为期5天的任务。我想，好吧，这是一份足够轻松的工作，所以我就去了。你能跟我说说吗？为了得到这份工作，发生了什么？所以我们应该在弗里蒙特的一家餐厅见面，那也是一个宴会厅。加利福尼亚州的弗里蒙特，是美国最大的阿富汗社区之一。
communities in the US. Which stuff says that at the Banking Hall, employees of an Alaska-based military contractor had set up tables where they handed out applications. They served food while people filled the mouth. They did serve us a very nice dinner, I remember that, traditional Afghan dish dinner. And we ate the dinner while we were signing up.
穆斯塔法说，在宴会厅里，一家阿拉斯加军事承包商的员工摆好了桌子，分发申请表。他们在人们填表的同时提供食物。我记得他们确实为我们提供了一顿非常丰盛的晚餐，传统的阿富汗菜肴。我们在边吃晚晚餐边报名。
Was there a particular type, if you will, who went for this kind of job? And if so, what was that type? I won't say any particular type. Obviously, it was disproportionately male. If I have to guess, probably it was 80% male and 20% female. They tended to be more people that had limited
有没有哪种特定类型的人会选择这种工作？如果有，那是哪种类型？我不会说有什么特定类型。很明显，男性的比例过高。如果我必须猜测的话，大概80%是男性，20%是女性。他们往往是那些英语说得有限的人，
ability to speak English and actually the company loved that they were primarily were targeting this community that spoke. No English or very limited amount of English because it brought even more attention to the role player. So if you really don't know how to speak English or very little understand of experience, so you can portray that more naturally. We stuff estimates there were at least 400 people there that night applying for the job.
事实上，公司非常喜欢他们主要针对这个说英语很少或英语说得非常有限的社区，因为这给角色扮演者带来了更多的真实感。如果你真的不会说英语或者懂很少的经验，你可以更自然地表现出来。穆斯塔法估计那天晚上至少有400人在那里申请这份工作。
The contractor, a company called TITLEC, was also performing on the spot drug tests and background checks. And then, at our midnight, we got boarded on the buses that was chartered by the company and we left free month all the way to 29 pounds. So pretty much I got hired on the spot for this shop. So the day you were hired was the day you went to 29 pounds? Yes, the script. Mustafa had never even heard of 29 palms before starting up to be a role player.
这家名为TITLEC的承包商还在现场进行药物测试和背景调查。然后，在大约半夜，我们登上了公司包租的巴士，从弗里蒙特一直开到了二十九棕榈村。所以基本上我当场就被这份工作录用了。所以你被录用的那天就是你去二十九棕榈村的日子？是的，剧本。在报名成为角色扮演者之前，穆斯塔法甚至没听说过二十九棕榈村。
It's a huge Marine Corps base near Joshua Tree National Park in Southern California's Mojave Desert. So once they took us in the base, they handed out the scripts for us. It said, hey, I memorized this. Remember your role, just follow the script. But my role was very left vague. I'm not sure if it was done on purpose. We had a lot of freedom to just improvise. The work they started at around 6.30 a.m. after a simple breakfast. Then Mustafa and the other role players boarded a bus that brought them to the field. That's where Mustafa first saw the mock village where he'd be working. It was built out of dress-stop-shipping containers. Everyone
它是加州莫哈韦沙漠中约书亚树国家公园附近的一个巨大的海军陆战队基地。所以一旦他们把我们带进基地，他们就给我们发了剧本。上面写着，嘿，背熟这个。记住你的角色，按剧本演就行。但我的角色非常模糊。我不确定这是不是故意的。我们有很多自由可以即兴发挥。他们在大约早上6点30分吃完简单的早餐后开始工作。然后穆斯塔法和其他角色扮演者登上了一辆将他们带到实地的巴士。那就是穆斯塔法第一次看到他将要工作的假村庄的地方。它是用货运集装箱搭建的。每个人
wore traditional clothes, and Mustafa says they weren't allowed to speak English, only Farsi and Pashdoh. Everything to Mustafa looked shockingly accurate. It really felt after the third day that I really was an Afghanistan because I was so immersed in that environment and that role. But there were also elements of his experience that were difficult or confusing for him and other role players. Some of the role players were recent refugees. They literally left one theater of war only to enter another. And sometimes, like in the case of one of Mustafa's friends, the simulation blurred the real and the fictional and upsetting ways.
都穿着传统服装，穆斯塔法说他们不允许说英语，只能说波斯语和普什图语。在穆斯塔法看来，一切都极其准确。呆了三天后，真的感觉自己置身于阿富汗，因为我太沉浸在那个环境和角色中了。但他的经历中也有一些部分对他和 其他角色扮演者来说是困难或令人困惑的。一些角色扮演者是新近的难民。他们刚离开一个战区，却又进入了另一个战区。有时，就像穆斯塔法的一个朋友的情况一样，模拟以令人不安的方式模糊了现实与虚构。
In another conversation we had over the phone, Mustafa told me about a friend of his who didn't speak much English, who had trouble grasping what his role was supposed to be. What he understood was that he was supposed to play a police officer, but he was actually supposed to play a police officer, working as an insider for the Taliban, and the Marines in this scenario were in fact on the hunt for his character. So when they found Mustafa's friend, they brought him in for interrogation and a Marine intelligence officer started accusing him of being part of the Taliban. So when they found Mustafa's friend, they brought him in for interrogation and a Marine intelligence officer started accusing him of being part of the Taliban.
在我们通过电话进行的另一次交谈中，穆斯塔法向我提起他的一个朋友，他英语说得不多，很难理解他的角色应该是什么。他所理解的是，他应该扮演一名警察，但他实际上应该扮演一名警察，作为塔利班的卧底为他们工作，而此场景中的海军陆战队员实际上正在追捕他的角色。因此，当他们找到穆斯塔法的朋友时，他们把他带去审讯，一名海军陆战队情报军官开始指控他是塔利班成员。因此，当他们找到穆斯塔法的朋友时，他们把他带去审讯，一名海军陆战队情报军官开始指控他是塔利班成员。
And Mustafa's friend, Crumble. And then he started panicking and said, oh, I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry, I can't think of you. They took my fingerprints via metrics. I'm good. I have a green card. I'm legally here. He was terrified.
穆斯塔法的朋友崩溃了。然后他开始惊慌失措，说，哦，我很抱歉，我很抱歉，我没想到。他们通过生物测识采集了我的指纹。我很好。我有绿卡。我是合法在这里的。他吓坏了。
And the interpreter started laughing and he tried to calm and comfort Mustafa's friend in his native language. He said, this is all pretend you're not being accused of being part of the Taliban. You're a role player. You will not get in trouble, you will not get arrested when you leave the job, because he thought he was going to get deported for being a Taliban. Reflecting back on that experience and how traumatizing it was for his friend, Mustafa says that working 12 hours a day, sometimes up to two weeks at a time,
翻译开始笑了起来，他试图用母语安抚穆斯塔法的朋友。他说，这都是假装的，没有人指控你是塔利班成员。你是一名角色扮演者。你不会惹麻烦，离开工作后也不会被捕，因为他以为自己会因为当塔利班而被驱逐出境。回想起那段经历以及这对他的朋友造成了多大的创伤，穆斯塔法说，每天工作12小时，有时甚至一次连续两周，
made it easy to forget you were in a simulation. We just got absorbed in that role and just forget that what you're doing is actually make believe as scenario not a real life, but then I guess we just lost sense of that. But even with these uncomfortable dynamics, Mustafa found that being a role player was a good job. He says the role players had comfortable sleeping quarters on the military base with nice beds, hot showers, and access to a gym. Rotations typically lasted two weeks
让人很容易忘记自己正身处模拟之中。我们只是全身心地投入到那个角色中，忘记了你正在做的事其实是虚构的场景，而不是现实生活，但我想我们只是失去了这种感觉。但即便有这些令人不适的动态，穆斯塔法发现当一名角色扮演者仍是一份不错的工作。他说，角色扮演者在军事基地里有舒适的宿舍，有舒适的床、热水澡和健身房。轮换通常持续两周。
at a time. Mustafa would learn about rotations at 29 palms through an automated phone message, the military contractors sent out to the role players. It was in English, Farsi, and Pashto. You would get a one week notice, and then they would say, hey, from this day to this day, there's a two week rotation coming up. If you're interested, press month, if you're not interested, press two. If they press one, they would then get more information about what time to arrive if they came on their own or how to catch the next charted bus from Fremont to 29 Poles. People that were working in that job, they were really very, very careful not to miss that phone call because they knew, after miss one time, they're going to get kicked out of the list of role players
穆斯塔法会通过军事承包商发送给角色扮演者的自动电话留言了解二十九棕榈村的轮换情况。那是用英语、波斯语和普什图语播报的。你会提前一周收到通知，然后他们会说，嘿，从这一天到那一天，将有为期两周的轮换。如果你有兴趣，请按1；如果你没兴趣，请按2。如果他们按1，他们就会获得更多关于何时到达的信息，无论是自己前往，还是如何乘坐从弗里蒙特到二十九棕榈村的下一班包车。做这份工作的人非常非常小心，生怕错过那个电话，因为他们知道，一旦错过一次，他们基本上就会被踢出角色扮演者的名单。
pretty much. And there was money to be made. Mustafa says at the time that he participated, role players earned about $1,000 to $1800 a week. Money that was especially meaningful to non-English speakers who might have struggled to get other kinds of work. And for contractors and subcontractors who build and staff these simulations, the money is even bigger. A year-long NBC News investigation published in 2019 found that since the early 2000s, the industry around these simulations has ballooned. NBC News investigation published in 2019 found that since the early 2000s, the industry around these simulations has ballooned. NBC News has identified a network of 256 companies in 46 states, providing role players and receiving more than a quarter of a billion dollars a year in government contracts.
而且能赚到钱。穆斯塔法说，在他参与的时期，角色扮演者每周大约能赚1000到1800美元。这笔钱对于那些可能难以找到其他工作的非英语母语者来说意义重大。而对于建造和为这些模拟提供人员的承包商和分包商来说，这笔钱甚至更多。2019年发表的一项为期一年的美国全国广播公司（NBC）新闻调查发现，自2000年代初以来，围绕这些模拟的行业已经膨胀。美国全国广播公司（NBC）2019年发布的调查发现，自2000年代初以来，围绕这些模拟的行业已经膨胀。NBC新闻发现了一个由46个州的256家公司组成的网络，他们提供角色扮演者，每年从政府合同中获得超过2.5亿美元的资金。
In 2009, the government accountability office found that the Department of Defense spent $94.8 million on these simulations, which means that by the time the NBC report came out a decade later, spending had more than doubled to over $250 million. And at the time of the 2019 report, there still hadn't been a comprehensive audit of that spending. Independent watchdog groups said these programs took off during the war on terror to serve an immediate need, and they were basically forgotten. But that doesn't mean they don't still warrant scrutiny.
2009年，政府问责局发现国防部在这些模拟上花费了9480万美元，这意味着到十年后NBC的报道出炉时，支出已经翻了一番多，达到超过2.5亿美元。而在2019年报告发布时，对这笔支出的全面审计仍未进行。独立监督组织表示，这些项目在反恐战争期间起飞，以满足紧迫的需求，随后基本上被遗忘了。但这并不意味着它们不值得接受审查。
Because now, even as the US has withdrawn from those wars, these training grounds aren't going away. They're just adapting. A reporter Sonia Paul takes us into one of these training grounds after the break. You can see how complex it's raining, right? Like flat, mountains, got some urban areas in it, right? In early 2023, I visited the National Training Center at Fort Irwin in Southern California. I was there along with a group of researchers, a few other members of the press, and some military family members. A lot more sand than trees and grass, right?
因为现在，即使美国已经从这些战争中撤出，这些训练场也没有消失。它们只是在适应。记者索尼娅·保罗在休息过后带我们进入其中一个训练场。你可以看到它的训练有多复杂，对吧？平坦的土地、山脉、还有一些城区，对吧？2023年初，我访问了位于加利福尼亚州南部欧文堡的国家训练中心。我和一群研究人员、其他几位媒体成员以及一些军人家属一起去了那里。沙子比树木和草多得多，对吧？
As we sat inside a yellow school bus, an army sergeant narrated what to look out for in the world we are about to enter. Endless smiles of erud-looking mountains surrounded us. Like 29 palms, Fort Irwin is also in the middle of California's Mahavi Desert, near the city of Barsto. And the training simulation we were headed to was the village formally known as Medina Wasole, the same village professor rights visiting. But now, it's been adapted for training for more current conflicts, like the war in Ukraine.
当我们坐在黄色校车里时，一名陆军中士讲述了在我们即将进入的世界中需要注意的事项。我们四周环绕着一望无际的荒凉山脉。就像二十九棕榈村一样，欧文堡也位于加州莫哈韦沙漠的中央，靠近巴斯托市。我们前往的训练模拟基地就是正式名称为麦地那·瓦塞尔的村庄，也就是赖斯教授参观过的那个村庄。但现在，它已经适应了乌克兰战争等近期冲突的训练。
Alright, so we're about to enter in what we call the city of Regis. Regis is made up of 785 buildings. It's the largest and most detailed of all the urban training villages. So we have schools, we've got an emissary, we've got a market square, we've got high-rise buildings, we've got sub-trail, tunnel systems, we've got a prison, right?
好的，所以我们即将进入我们所说的雷日市。雷日由785栋建筑组成。它是所有城市训练村中最大、最详细的一个。所以我们有学校、使馆、集市广场、高层建筑、地铁、隧道系统、监狱，对吧？
Regis is intended to simulate a contested border city between the make-believe countries of Denovia and Atropia. Denovia is nominally a republic, but functionally an authoritarian state. Atropia is an oil-rich western-leaning oligarchy. Both are Muslim-majority nations in the Caucasus region of the world. The general on the tour told me the army is looking to hire role players who can speak more Eastern-Black languages, like Russian, Polish, Ukrainian, and Armenian. If you pay attention to the signs, it's in Russian, it changes to Russian. So they're replicating the fight in Ukraine. Since there weren't any soldiers actually using the training ground, what we saw on the
雷日旨在模拟虚构国家德诺维亚（Denovia）和阿特罗皮亚（Atropia）之间有争议的边境城市。德诺维亚名义上是一个共和国，但在职能上是一个独裁国家。阿特罗皮亚是一个富油的、亲西方的寡头政体。两国都是高加索地区穆斯林人口占多数的国家。巡视中的将军告诉我，军队正准备聘请能够说更多东欧语言（如俄语、波兰语、乌克兰语和亚美尼亚语）的角色扮演者。如果你注意路标，它是俄语的，会变成俄语。所以他们在复制乌克兰的战斗。由于没有士兵真正使用该训练场，我们在
tour was a sort of simulation of a simulation. Other than a couple of fake attacks and explosions to show us the Hollywood style special effects that the military uses, there wasn't any simulated combat going on. It almost felt like the tours of Universal Studios, my family and I went to when I was a kid. At one stop, our army tour guides even took us to shoot blinks from some machine gun. You know, like I give a say, should try it, but here's what now we're never going to do. Trying to take in everything during the tour was a lot.
参观中看到的是一种对模拟的模拟。除了几次虚假的袭击和爆炸来向我们展示军方使用的好莱坞式特效之外，没有任何模拟战斗在进行。这几乎感觉像是环球影城的导游，我和家人在我小时候去过的那样。在其中一站，我们的军队导游甚至带我们去用机枪发射空包弹。你知道，就像我说的那样，应该试试，但这才是我们永远不会做的事。试图在参观过程中吸收所有东西是一件很累人的事。
It was overly stimulating and surreal. Walking through War-Torn Reziche with its Lego-like buildings, piles of rubble, a lonely-looking mosque, and a bizarre. and the bizarre. The bizarre wasn't very big. It was a sort of wide alley butchers by short, tan colored buildings made out of corrugated material. Hockers were selling housewares, eggs, fruits, vegetables, meat on a stick. My guess was that the point of the scene was to fill us and future soldiers with culture
它过于刺激且超现实。穿过饱受战争蹂躏的雷日，那里有乐高般的建筑、成堆的瓦砾、一座孤零零的清真寺和一个集市。和集市。集市不是很大。那是一种宽阔的小巷，两旁是由瓦楞材料建造的矮小、棕色的建筑物。小贩们在卖家居用品、鸡蛋、水果、蔬菜、肉串。我猜这个场景的目的是让我们和未来的士兵充满文化
shock. But I was more excited to interview the fake mayor of Rizesh. I tried to ask him about his job as a role player through his translator, but he refused to break character. Can I ask her, like, how does one find this kind of job? Since this ended up being a little awkward, I quickly adjusted to ask him a question within the scenario. How did you come to be mayor of Brazil? How do you become a mayor of this city? Как вы стали мэром этого города? Мы нас начале правительства отропей. Да, это все, что в городе.
冲击。但我更兴奋的是采访雷日的假市长。我试图通过他的翻译询问他关于作为角色扮演者的工作，但他拒绝跳出角色。我可以问她，比如，人们是怎么找到这种工作的？由于这最终有点尴尬，我迅速调整，用场景内的问题问他。你是怎么成为雷日的市长的？你怎么成为这个城市的市长？你怎么成了这个城市的市长？是的，这就是城市里的所有人。
Так что вы чувствуете меня? Так, это не власть, но люди. Нет, это власть, как... Это обычный выбор? Нет, ситуация визная, это виборе, пока у слювья не тут лиа вибра. Гасадарства, прав river election, that's why. Oh, I see. And it's...
所以你觉得我怎么样？是的，这不是权力，而是人民。不，这是权力，就像……这是普通的选举吗？不，情况很特殊，这是选举，直到条件……国家举行真正的选举，这就是原因。哦，我明白了。而且它是……
Right. And what is the population of a river? Talking to the mayor and translator was bizarre and almost fun in a disturbing way. It felt like the three of us were knowing participants in some weird role-playing game, rather than an intense warfare simulation. And the fact that I was there on a tour made the situation even more perplexing. That war had become a kind of Disneyland. So coming out here as a junior member in the army from a tiny little farm town in West Texas,
对。雷日的人口是多少？与市长和翻译交谈是离奇的，以一种令人不安的方式几乎很有趣。感觉我们三个人是在参加某种奇怪的角色扮演游戏，而不是激烈的战争模拟。而我在那里参观的事实使情况更加令人费解。战争已经变成了一种迪士尼乐园。作为一个来自西得克萨斯州一个小农场的陆军下级成员来到这里，
it truly felt like deploying to another country, right? This is Captain Steven Covey. And when you drive that 30 minute drive down the road from Barstow, you do really feel like you're going to know where. And which is kind of a helpful feeling out here that you do feel like you're just in its own, its own world for the scenarios that we create out here. And that's major Robert Roads. The three of us sat down and spoke after the tour. They told me that denovia and atropia have been a fixture military simulations since the 80s.
这真的感觉像是被部署到另一个国家，对吧？这是史蒂芬·科维上尉。当你开车沿着那条路从巴斯托行驶30分钟时，你真的感觉你要去一个未知的地方。这是一种很有帮助的感觉，你会觉得你只是在我们在这里创造的场景中处于它自己的世界中。那是罗伯特·罗兹少校。我们三个人在参观后坐下来谈了谈。他们告诉我，德诺维亚和阿特罗皮亚自80年代以来一直是军事模拟的固定设施。
And these fake countries have their own lore within the military's culture. I had a t-shirt that said, American blood isn't worth a trophy and oil or something like that. And that's the idea behind it. It's just everyone understands it. You'll see a trophy and veteran bumper stickers and stuff
这些假国家在军队文化中拥有自己的背景故事。我有一件T恤，上面写着“美国人的血不值得阿特罗皮亚的石油”或类似的话。这就是背后的想法。这只是每个人都明白的道理。你会看到阿特罗皮亚老兵的保险杠贴纸之类的东西
like the cabinets. It's an inside joke for that reason. Captain Covey and Major Rhodes also emphasize that these simulations have only become more psychologically and logistically complex in recent years. For the past year between Russia and Ukraine, we've had the opportunity to watch an invasion happen through the lens of social media, and it's absolutely fascinating. It's become clear that preparing for war now takes more than just practicing on a physical battlefield. The theater of war is also online, so on top of training for combat and counterinsurgency
像内阁一样。出于这个原因，这是一个内部笑话。科维上尉和罗兹少校还强调，近年来，这些模拟在心理和后勤上变得越来越复杂。在过去一年俄罗斯和乌克兰的冲突中，我们有机会通过社交媒体的镜头目睹了一场入侵的发生，这绝对令人着迷。显而易见的是，为战争做准备现在需要的不仅仅是在实体战场上练习。战争剧场也在网上，所以在这些模拟中训练战斗和反游击战的同时，
in these simulations, the National Training Center has also created its own social media system to mimic this other aspect of modern warfare. The soldiers are forced to quickly react to these different information streams. Some of the social media posts might be pointing out something the soldiers did wrong. Some of it might also be pure disinformation that the denovians who are the so-called
国家训练中心还创建了自己的社交媒体系统，以模仿现代战争的这一其他方面。士兵们被迫对这些不同的信息流迅速作出反应。一些社交媒体帖子可能会指出士兵做错的事情。其中一些也可能纯粹是德诺维亚人（即情景中的所谓坏人）试图传播的虚假信息。所以现在他们必须对虚假信息做出反应，平息事态，并帮助塑造叙事，把他们的关于训练事件中正在发生的事情的真相故事讲出来。这绝对是现代士兵无论好坏都必须继续面对的事情。军队不仅在为可能发生的冲突做准备
bad guys in the scenario might be trying to propagate. So now they have to react to disinformation, firemen, and kind of help shape the narrative and get their story on the truth out of what's going on in the training event. And it's absolutely something that the modern day soldiers going to have to continue with, both good and bad. The Army isn't just preparing for possible conflicts
在东欧。《纽约时报》报道称，美国陆军目前正在夏威夷丛林中训练，以防范与中国发生冲突的可能性。美军总是放眼未来，为地平线上的下一场冲突做准备。我采访了其他曾在世界各地虚构国家扮演角色的角色扮演者。还有图尔比亚（Turbia）、科蒂纳（Cortina）、爱尔兰共和国、派龙人民共和国（People's Republic of Pylon），这只是其中少数几个。
in Eastern Europe. The New York Times reported that the US Army is now training in the Hawaiian jungle to prepare for the possibility of conflict with China. The US military is always looking to the future, preparing for the next conflict they see on the horizon. I spoke with other role players who have role-played in fictional countries all over the world. There is also Turbia, Cortina, the Republic of Ireland, the People's Republic of Pylon, just to name a handful.
我甚至在Indeed.com上看到了当前对角色扮演者的招聘信息。当面试时不一定需要外语流利，但申请者必须能够扮演外语说话者的角色。这可能包括说，引用原话，“胡言乱语”。这证明了这些模拟并没有消失，而是在不断演变，以满足军队最新的需求。但战争不仅仅是军队经历的。这些模拟还提供了过去所有冲突的某种档案，以及美式军国主义在世界许多地方的沉重遗产。穆斯塔法说，他对成为一名角色扮演者没有任何心理负担。
I even came across current job listings for role players on ND.com. When seated at foreign language fluency isn't necessary, but that applicants must be able to act as a foreign language speaker. And that can include speaking, quote, gibberish. It's a testament to how these simulations don't go away, but are instead evolving to meet the military's latest needs. But a war is not just experienced by the military. And these simulations also provide a kind of archive of all the conflicts of the past and the difficult legacy of US militarism and so many places around the world. Mustafa says he had no qualms about being a role player.
我甚至在ND.com上看到了针对角色扮演者的当前招聘启事。当外语流利并非必需时，应聘者必须能够扮演外语说话者。这可能包括说，引述一下，胡言乱语。这证明了这些模拟并没有消失，而是在不断演变以满足军方的最新需求。但战争不仅仅是由军方经历的。这些模拟还提供了一种档案，记录了过去的所有冲突以及美国军国主义在世界各地许多地方的艰难遗产。穆斯塔法说，他对成为一名角色扮演者没有任何顾虑。
He wanted to make sure that US troops were trained to be as culturally competent as possible before entering Afghanistan. But when the U.S. military withdrew from Afghanistan in 2021, after 20 years of war and occupation, the Taliban captured Kabul within 10 days. And Mustafa began to have questions about how much or how little the military had actually learned from the simulations. Mustafa himself had worked as a translator in Afghanistan between Stance Working as a role player, and he remains invested in helping the Afghan community. So when thousands of Afghan refugees were coming to the US, Mustafa traveled to Indiana,
他希望确保美军在进入阿富汗之前，接受尽可能多的文化适应培训。然而，当美国军队在经历20年的战争与占领后，于2021年从阿富汗撤出时，塔利班在10天内就攻占了喀布尔。穆斯塔法开始对军队从这些模拟演练中究竟学到了多少（或多吉少）产生疑问。穆斯塔法本人曾在阿富汗担任翻译和角色扮演人员，他至今仍致力于帮助阿富汗社群。因此，当成千上万的阿富汗难民来到美国时，穆斯塔法前往了印第安纳州，
where one of the state's major military sites had been transformed. Not into a simulation, but into a temporary home for evacuees. In the chaos of resettling, Musoffa saw that the US Army had placed warring ethnic tribes inside by side living quarters. One kid gave another kid a black eye and lots of tension and I understood quickly right away. This was a very bad combination and a bad thing to do. And then I looked at a social army, it was just looked like it was a deer caught in a headlight. It was just so confused and disoriented. He didn't know how to deal with that situation.
该州的主要军事基地之一已被改造成。不是为了模拟演练，而是成为撤离人员的临时住所。在混乱的安置过程中，穆斯塔法发现美军将相互敌对的部族安排在相邻的起居室内。一个孩子把另一个孩子的眼睛打青了，矛盾重重，我立刻明白这绝对是一个糟糕的组合，也是一件错误的做法。然后我看着美国士兵，他们就像一只在车灯前受惊的小鹿，感到无比困惑和迷茫，根本不知道该如何处理那种局面。
They were unprepared for the crisis that happened, the highway equation, and then having to deal with resoupling 72,000 people with a couple of months. It was not an easy task. It was very, very challenging. The military had prepared to fight in Afghanistan. It had trained in fictional villages like the one Mustafa worked in. But to Mustafa, it didn't look like they prepared
他们对这场危机的发生毫无准备，即撤离的方程，还要在几个月内应对重新安置72万人的任务。这绝非易事，非常非常具有挑战性。军队一直在为在阿富汗作战做准备，并在像穆斯塔法工作过的那种虚构村庄里进行训练。但在穆斯塔法看来，这并不像是他们为
for what would come after the occupation, once they were gone and preparing for the next war. 99% of visible was reported this week by Sonya Paul, edited by Vivian Leigh with help from Delaney Hall, with additional production by Jacob Moldenano Medina. Mixed in sound design by Martin Gonzales, music byohlstedt, is our digital director. The resident includes Chris Barrupe, Jason Dalyone, Emmith Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Sarah Baker, and me Roman Morris. The 99% of his well-known logo was created by Staffin Lawrence. Special thanks this week to the National Training Center and Fort Irwin, and to Wasam Albadri, Lidia Mugyanis, Justin Garrison, Keith Emanne, Jenny Gammaj, Terrence Brown, Kimberly Hackbarth,
占领结束后的情况做好了准备——一旦他们离开，就要为下一场战争做准备。《99%无形》本周由索尼亚·保罗报道，维维安·利编辑，德兰尼·霍尔协助，雅各布·莫尔德纳诺·梅迪纳参与制作。混音与声音设计由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，音乐由奥尔斯特德创作，他是我们的数字总监。常驻人员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、杰森·达利昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉谢玛·唐、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普赖姆、萨拉·贝克以及我罗曼·莫里斯。《99%无形》知名的标志由斯塔芬·劳伦斯创作。本周特别鸣谢国家训练中心和欧文堡，以及瓦萨姆·阿尔巴德里、莉迪亚·穆吉亚尼斯、贾斯汀·加里森、基思·埃曼、珍妮·加马杰、特伦斯·布朗、金伯利·哈克巴思、
Ben Wadenbo, Stephen Graham, Selene Ellsway, and Nomi Stone. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious Ex-M podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites if you want to feel bad about your life, but if you want to feel good, then I recommend you go to our website where you can find other Stitcher shows I love. And every past episode of 99PI, that website is 99 Empire dot org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本·瓦登博、斯蒂芬·格雷厄姆、塞琳·埃尔斯韦和诺米·斯通。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区的潘多拉大厦向北六个街区。如果你想对自己的生活感到糟糕，可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们；但如果你想感觉良好，我建议你去我们的网站，在那里你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目以及《99PI》的每一集过往节目，网址是99percentinvisible.org。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。